[Musique]
où
oui l'âge à presque toutes les fêtes
religieuses
tu t'es qui seraient attachées très
friands du cérémonial et du rite
durée trois mains c'était si vous voulez
leur spectacle c'était leurs tréteaux de
france où les émissions guy lux alors
installé punk alors les gens venaient
pour voir ce déploiement de faste ne
correspondait d'ailleurs un état d'âme à
une mise en condition que l'on appelle
le spiritisme moyenâgeux et les baladins
les montreurs d'ours les saltimbanques
profiter de cette occasion de ce grand
rassemblement de foule pour venir les
uns vendent leurs produits des autres
contrées leur adresse et autres montres
et du merveilleux enfin faire argent de
leur talent et de leur possibilités on
pourrait en déduire également que le
clergé du moyen-âge a été les a été en
somme le précurseur des deux couples en
tant qu'agence du voyage parce qu'il
s'entendait ou même de muscle tri kalou
qui n'a rien inventé parce que déjà à
l'époque qu'ils avaient inventé six
voyages organisés en masques et nous
nous en avons profité
et puis depuis il 560 cette
manifestation à subsister sur les lieux
mêmes c'est à dire la place de la nation
et le cours de vincennes
les révolutions passèrent on a décapité
les rois on a débaptisé les places on
voulait plus entendre parler de de
tronyo de couronnes et on voulait
publier tout ce qui pouvait rappeler la
monarchie où les mêmes les dynasties qui
se sont succédé mais il ya une chose qui
subsistent et qui était une sorte de
pérennité dans l'histoire de france
c'est la famille rôle car aujourd'hui
encore il s'appelle la fois détruite
[Musique]
il y a dans notre profession de ce que
je pourrais appeler larmes forem
c'est un phénomène un peu particulier et
mais j'ai vécu en dehors de ce métier
j'ai fait d'autres métiers
mais dans aucun autre dans aucune autre
collectivité humaine ou professionnelle
je n'ai retrouvé 70 ce climat qui est
véritablement très particulier à notre
profession
lima qui est composé de coin manière de
penser manière de réfléchir manière de
raisonner qui est absolument particulier
à ce milieu et je certains trouvent que
ses pittoresques je l'admets bien
volontiers c'est certainement pitot h
pour ceux qui voient le problème de
l'extérieur pour ceux qui le voient de
l'intérieur ça représente quand même
certains inconvénients ne serait ce que
au point de vue évolution de notre
métier car notre métier besoin d'évoluer
comme plus sûrs autres industries et je
crois que ce conservatisme
chen justement pour repenser notre
métier nous intégrer à la vie moderne
nous avons un milieu qui est extrêmement
hétérogène qui est composé de comment
dirais je d'activité très divers et le
seul dénominateur commun qui existe
entre ses différentes activités
entre ces différentes exploitations
c'est l'entité fête foraine
[Musique]
en
on
[Musique]
vous avez eu quelques petits ennuis a
pas très longtemps
[Musique]
ah bon
pas grave enfin il ya eu des petits
ennuis par l'intermédiaire de cette
jalousie que j'ai tout dire et bhl était
en hausse le ton sérieux pour cela marie
très gentil très corrélé savez il ya eu
un petit montage de coûts mais en face
c'est vague
enfin vous vous en méfiez real occasion
parce que c'est une personne qui causa
cvd trop vite que ce que vous pensez et
alors voyez vous en l'air en disant trop
vos pensées on cherche à vous nuire
alors c'est ce qu'il faut éviter
et vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
volontaire j'ai dit indépendante bruit
pessimisme également ce qui est une
tendance de donner un complexe
d'infériorité
ouah cela est dû aux événements
antérieurs
en effet nous faisait une personne qui
avait un monde venus pardon tout de
suite sur le principe le sentimental
mais en même temps vous avez un mont
soleil et un mont mercure qui sont liées
la nage
ce mont soleil n'indique que vous avez
des prédispositions renaître sur une
base artistique dix ans mais qui
reculent tendance de tomber dans le
domaine public pour devenir commercial
[Musique]
le mob en christ c'est une vieille ville
histoire et je ne voudrais pas vous l'a
relaté nous voulons expliquer mais ce
sont les artistes qui se produisaient
lors de notre dame sur des tréteaux un
banquier c'est une ce sont des gens qui
travaillent sur des plantes un artiste
de cirque loyer n'est pas un banquier
c'est un vent qui est quand même parce
que nous avons beaucoup de banquise dans
nos amis mais pour le mot baptiste vient
de travailler sur un tréteau sur les
planches comme on le faisait si bien sûr
les bords de l'autre d'âme lorsqu'il y
avait les arracheurs de dents il y avait
les physiciens l'ebroïcien ce sont des
banques
[Musique]
pour ma part ça va faire cinquante ans
que je fais départ du trou car je suis
ni cours de vincennes dans une caravane
foraine et
a présenté l'établissement depuis
soixante dix ans à paris
[Musique]
mais les vrais retours et c'est parti en
les rejetant leur le bailleur doit elle
si le veinard et l'intention l'arrivée
lever la tension
le gagnant l'arrivée à voilà le veinard
un jérôme hispa paris c'est la foire de
montbard m inspire mais ni le montant
c'est bon ça j'ai toujours les mêmes
clients les clients paris dans quelles
conditions vous en avez tous fait le
numéro 500 non je ne sais jamais vos
billets messieurs dames avant tout de
suite après les veillées jaune investira
maintenant devient un métier un métier
comme un autre chose on vient aux normes
helvétiques à vrai dire vous trouvez le
soir on a notre pays on vient on nous
écoute et qu'on trouve nos clients on
referme on rentre chez nous ses petites
protégées dans tandis que dans le temps
évidemment les cinq voire sept autres
deux fois 100 à des bilans qui sont
entièrement qui doit coller
j'ai eu mon document là ils sont venus
commence à jouer tout payer ils sortent
par an mais après on continue de jouer
les antilles font et se marier ils ont
toute la loterie milk et vous arrivez
chez eux ce soir les meubles fauteuils
tout bien là le degré pitié moi je vais
dire son âge mais j'ai 50 ans et à 50,11
la quatrième génération à avoir du tour
je reviens vers les jeunes d'abord cours
de vincennes n'est pas ici mais c'était
toujours un peu près pareil mais il y
avait beaucoup plus de grands travaux
n'ayant de ce qu'on appelait la bande
dans le temps souvent brillé jeudi son
du circuit y avait le cirque avait des
ménageries evo qu'autre chose
si amiens beaucoup plus de monde dans le
champ de foire bio vert pour la
prochaine partie vous pouvez commencer à
vous faire servir la même et la
paralysie pour les agents devant
j'arrose à l'os et aussi tout ce qui est
d'installer envoie chaque côté vous avez
des services accor a rappelé aux
déménageurs en u9 et les jours et bien
si vous en voulez les billets jaune
[Musique]
oh
oui
[Musique]
on
où
[Musique]
oh
je
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si on compte le nombre de friterie sur
la fête du trône je pense que ça fait de
quantité imposante plus le nombre de
visiteurs pour les week-ends par exemple
ne pas qu'ils sont très importants quand
le soleil est avec nous chaque fête à
son caractère
[Musique]
vous avez les fêtes comme la fête des
loges les 24 heures du mans c'est la
fête de l'automobile brio et ici c'est
un peu si vous voulez la vraie fête
foraine la fête populaire
un peu comme dans la chanson dans le
temps à l'agent la restauration général
aussi bien dans les sédentaires que
dolan sur l'inter c'est mon métier je
laime mais j'ai toujours un plaisir à
pratiquer ou fr dès réception
comme nous avons fait là bas du drom
nous avons aussi une année ameliste
sur un lecteur cd frites menthe et du
manger les fruits mais agrémenté de
quelques bricoles nous avons su les
pieux du 12e ma préférence va à
l'ambiance de la foire c'est un métier
très dur mais on a l'impression d'avoir
été une certaine liberté
chaque année je vais voir uniquement
dans pareil ici à la fois de trop
simplement
parent plus
ça c'est un mois sans résultat apparent
chose
d moi je chantais pas de sens parce que
c'est pas sortir l'hiver j'ai des
traumatismes au cerveau et notre société
on a la guerre des mots linge et qu'un
prisonnier clientes et c'est un forain
les clientèles des bouffées dévié gens
j'ai des petits-enfants c'est je prépare
à se détendre hui parce que j'ai pas de
flash
wipro juillet je veux pas passer la nuit
instantanément dans des seconds et dans
la photo allons-y ciel qui tourne mal et
finit 6e réforme tourne exprime bien ce
jeu de force vous chargez pas du porno
n'ont pas toujours reçu les points c'est
un peu plus loin là bas je vous dois 50
centimes à la jeune homme avant que
j'étais à l'alimentation
c'est beaucoup plus
dur certains moments que vous soyez et
d'autres moments c'est ça dépend avant
je n'en prési
est attendue des cendres s'étende aux
produits sains
c'est déjà lieu des nahdhaouis des
talents des primo la députée jouer comme
ça avec les enfants ça la portion allant
d acer pas vendre diverti la chanson de
rolland courbis
[Musique]
alors le monde le français c'est des
prix métier ça
c'est voudriez à
1ère 2007 une c'est vraiment la grosse
entreprise au sein de la foi voyons sans
blabla c'est une preuve aux entreprises
qui représentent 45 tonnes de matériaux
différents taux sa réalisation il ya 125
éléments d'environ 4 mètres qui
constitue un parcours accidenté nous
mentent et pour l'agrément du public
avec des montées et des descentes en ce
moment vous entendez le clic aide les
cliques et de sécurité parce que vous
avez abandonné crime 11,7 un vieux
principe c'est le principe des chariots
dans les mines on n'a rien inventé
pour monter il nous faut une douzaine
d'ouvriers g8 ouvriers spécialisés qui
restent les 365 jours de l'année et
après le présent appel à la main
d'oeuvre locale c'est-à-dire les
chômeurs du doigt et cetera et cetera et
cetera
[Musique]
une tournée qui est vraiment des limites
et la peur du trône pour nous et notre
point d'attaché l'âme et nous démarrons
les gros problème en ce moment ce sont
surtout les manque d'emplacements les
emplacements disparaissent dans le
centre ville
on essaie de nous les portons pas de
nous évader c'est surtout le les
transports les stationnements qui nous
aide qui oblige les certaines
municipalités à nous mettre autour des
portes dans certaines villes dans des
terrains qui sont pas toujours aménagé
un cardinal fait le talent l'avait dit
une fois le gardinal partie là d'une
autre corps réalité nous sommes les
ouvriers de la joie
[Musique]
où
là
non
[Musique]
en
on fait un mauvais caractère
les eschois voyez vous mesdames
messieurs sont des fours sauvage de pons
qui viennent d'arriver
ils ne sont pas encore complètement
brécé alors des pechs loire il n'y a que
trois mois seulement que nous
annoncerons ancien construit dans leur
cage
la première fois celle ci a priori
karaté
[Musique]
à lomé
nous allons présenter ces demoiselles au
public a marqué son visage public en a b
c ie a marqué ce teint basané se tasse
il ya car ces demoiselles et sicilien
d'origine internationale
[Musique]
ça y est vous étiez reste année elle
aimait de marcel nous allons partir vie
de doucement nos vies ça y est vous êtes
bien en place lee vous savez bien tirer
vos barres de sécurité et vous
mesdemoiselles attention si vous avez
des perruques et postiches des pentes y
accrocher des biens
allez on va bien se chauffer à plat long
lent que ça va faire sitôt que la
demoiselle au tipi de cus
[Musique]
non
ans
[Musique]
où